Rumänien hat eine
bärenplage sie kommen den Menschen immer
näher sie sind nicht nur niedlich sie
sind
gefährlich abschießen sagen die einen
andere sehen in neuer Technologie die
Lösung sicher ist der Mensch und sein
Konsum haben mitchuld am
bärenproblem in Benin in den Kaparten
sind die Müllcontainer deshalb
eingeschlossen die
antibärenmaßnahme hat aber Lücken am
Rand des Neubaugebiets finden wir diese
Müllkippe mit Fell und Schlachtabfällen
für geruchsempfindliche Bären wie eine
Einladung der Bär sucht Futter er hat
nicht genug Futter im
Wald deshalb kommt er hier in unsere
Straßen ich traue mich nicht mehr in den
Wald früher haben wir dort Pilze
gesammelt aber jetzt haben wir zu viel
Angst viele in Berlin arbeiten im Westen
erfüllen sich aber hier den Traum vom
eigenen
Haus das Dorf rückt dem Wald immer
näher auf dem nahen Hügel merkt der
cheäfer Zabo dass der Bär die Scheu vor
Menschen verliert und dass es immer mehr
Bären wirden seit 7 Jahren ist der
Abschuss streng
reguliert wir haben Zeh mal mehr
Attacken von Bären als vor 10 Jahren
früher haben wir sie vielleicht ein oder
zweimal pro Sommer gesehen jetzt sehen
wir sie fast jeden
Tag zu nah kommen sie Zabo meint sie
müssten wieder gejagt werden wie
früher er ist recht nach dem Vorfall vom
letzten Jahr sein Onkel wollte einen
Bären von den Schafen wegscheuchen
attierte ih 111 Stiche musste er machen
lassen und als Schäfer will er nicht
mehr arbeiten ich sage nicht dass wir
den Bären nicht schützen sollen aber sie
vermehren sich zu stark ich finde sie
sind zu sehr
geschützt nirgends in Europa sind Wälder
Dichter
wilder die Karpaten
draulanden wollen die Bären da sehen wo
sie hingehören tief im
Wald wir müssen leise sein unauffällige
Kleidung tragen und kein Deo um die
geruchsempfindlichen Bären nicht zu
vertreiben wir sitzen sicher hinter Glas
hier 12 km von jeder Besiedlung werden
Bären angefüttert auch um sie von den
Dörfern fernzalten erklärt uns
Simona es passiert hufig dass sie den
Dörfern nahe kommen in die Felder die
Gärten
Obstwiesen seit einiger Zeit können
Bewohner sich kaum noch wehren gegen die
bärenattacken Dorfbewohner sind richtig
frustriert deshalb locken sie sie tief
in den Wald mit ein paar Leckerein denn
Bären sind und bleiben
Wildtiere wenn das wirklich so ist dass
sie in die Dörfer gehen dann ist es doch
besser sie mit Futter davon
fernzuhalten Bären haben alle Gäste
bisser nur im Zoo
gesehen es ist so viel besser als ein
Zoo und sie sind hier glücklicher denn
sie sind in der Wildnis leben ihr
normales Leben sie haben 70 € dafür
gezahlt echte wilde beären zu sehen
Sichtung dank Fütterung garantiert denn
der Bär ist ein
Gewohnheitstier sie sind faule
Opportunist
immer die einste
futterelle und das ist auch das Problem
denn Touristen füttern beären entlang
der
Straßen sie erziehen sie so zu
bettelbeeren der Mensch lockt das ist
dein Grund warum der Bär nun häufiger in
die Zivilisation kommt der Mensch
zerstört das ist ein
anderer bei der NGO Agent green er nimmt
uns mit tief in den Wald ein Natura 2000
[Musik]
Gebiet hier darf nur eingeschränkt
abgeholzt werden und man muss sofort
nachpflanzen vor z Jahren wurde hier
zuletzt abgeholzt nachgepflanzt wurde
nichts einen Bär haben sie hier schon
lange nicht mehr
gesehen wegen derung der Bär abgewandert
und wenn er hier nichts zu fressen
findet dann muss er ja in Richtung
Dörfer gehen wo er zuverlässig Futter
findet der Holztransport hat den Bach
zerstört und D zeigt uns auch dass im
Naturschutzgebiet eine neue Straße
gebaut wird wenn dan und seine Freunde
dagegen vorgehen kann es gefährlich
werden meine Kollegen wurden schon mit
bedroht und sie haben die walstraen
verschlossen die Waldarbeiter nutzen oft
einschüchterungstaktiken und leider
werden wir von Seiten der Behörden nicht
unterstüzt auf der Fahrt fällt uns
dieser Laster auf dercheckt ob er wie
vorgeschrieben bei Ladung das Holz zum
Transp wir haben längst Netz
das Holz bleibt unregistriert so läuft
der Betrug erklärt dan der Fahrer lässt
einfach sein Handy aus normalerweise
würde den ihn anzeigen aber der Fahrer
merkt dass wir ihm folgen und meldet
nach nun ist alles legal dan muss ihn
ziehen
lassen das System hat riesen Fehler ich
meine das ist mit Absicht so
gemacht die Holzmafia verstärkt das
bärenproblem meint dan das Geld aus dem
Holz sei der Politik wichtiger als die
Tiere in Bukarest besuche ich den neuen
Umweltminister wieder einer der schwört
gegen Vermüllung illegales abholzen und
Korruption vorzugehen für das bärenprem
aber sieht mircha FIS drei Lösungswege
abschießen einzäunen
oder der Export man könnte einige Bären
in andere Länder
exportieren
wir müssen diese Last der größten
bärpopulation Europas Teilen genau wie
wir in der EU auch andere Lasten
Teilen in der Provinz werden sie auf die
migrationvereinbarung für Bären kaum
warten können jeden Abend so berichtet
es uns Anna bricht hier der Bär durch
den er rannte und ich hörte
ihn
und er sprang so
hoch die einzige Lösung ist das
Gewehr doch in ihrem Dorf probieren Sie
was neues aus zeigt mir Umweltschützer
mi Zotter diese Lautsprecher haben den
Bären vertrieben er war offenbar in hast
hinterließ noch ein paar Spuren
Kameras und Lautsprecher werden hier mit
künstlicher Intelligenz
gesteuert das ist neu der Alarm wird nur
ausgelöst wenn ein Bär vorbeikommt die
künstliche Intelligenz erkennt nicht nur
eine Bewegung sondern den
Bären wird ein Bär erkannt kommt
Musik oder ein aggressives
bärenbrüllen so soll ein Bär dauerhaft
vergrault werden wenn das nicht gelingt
muss er geschossen werden sagt sogar
miai er hofft auf
KI wenn die Akzeptanz für Bären Rumänien
so schlecht bleibt wie jetzt hat der Bär
keine sehr gute
Zukunft wir benötigen natürliche Gebiete
die groß genug sind damit der Bär leben
kann ohne menschliche
Beeinflussung so groß die Karpaten sind
sie werden zu klein für beide aber sie
gehören den Bären genau wie den
Menschen
ه